[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend den Sport
hat an diesem Freitag Sven fost für Sie
schönen guten Abend schauen wir auf die
großen Themen dieser Sendung
Entsetzen und Fassungslosigkeit in Prag
nach der Attacke an einer Uni mit 14
Toten ist das des Täters weiter
unklar Flut Hochwasser umgestürzte Bäume
Sturmtief soltern fegt mit voller Wucht
über Deutschland bundesweit gibt es
Ausfälle bei der Bahn und trau Ingrid
Steger die Schauspielerin ist im Alter
von 76 Jahren
gestorben tagelang wurde um den genauen
Wortlaut gerungen jetzt gibt es die
Einigung der UN Sicherheitsrat hat sich
auf eine Resolution zum nahenosten
verständigt un-gensekretär guteres trat
gerade vor die Presse in der Resolution
wird unter anderem eine Aufstockung der
humanitären Hilfe für die Menschen im
Gazastreifen gefordert die USA und
Russland enthielten sich bei der
Abstimmung und die Sitzung des un-
Sicherheitsrates hat Claudia Bates für
uns verfolgt Claudia was hat zur
Einigung
geführt das hat ja wirklich sehr lange
gedauert zum Schluss waren die USA recht
isoliert als sie Z letzt ihr Veto gegen
Resolution eingelegt hatten der
US-Regierung waren im Wesentlichen zwei
Dinge wichtig zum einen dass der Terror
der Hamas verurteilt wird und zum
anderen dass Israel das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat also kein
Waffenstillstand gefordert wird und nun
ist die Resolution so stark aufgeweicht
dass die USA zumindest kein Veto mehr
eingelegt haben
der Terror der Hamas wird nicht
verurteilt aber zumindest
wird nur die so heißt es Schaffung der
Voraussetzungen für eine dauerhafte
Einstellung der Feindseligkeiten
gefordert und eben keine unmittelbare
Waffenruhe und es wird eine
bedingungslose Freilassung der Geiseln
gefordert was den USA auch sehr wichtig
war im wesentlichen geht's jetzt um
humanitäre Hilfe und die Einhaltung von
internationalem Recht und dazu haben die
USA die Israel bereits die ganze Zeit
aufgerufen und insofern konnten sich
darauf nun wirklich alle verständigen
und was bedeutet die Resolution für
Israel ja also es gibt schon viele
Resolutionen zum Nahen Osten über die
Jahre und auch wenn die aus dem UN
Sicherheitsrat verbindlich sind gibt es
eben doch keine wirklichen
durchsetzungsmechanismen und insofern
muss man sehen wie Israel damit jetzt
umgeht eigentlich ist die israelische
Regierung jetzt gefordert die humanitäre
Situation der Menschen in Gaza zu
verbessern alle Wege als also auch alle
Grenzübergänge für Hilfe zu öffnen und
diese zu ermöglichen sofortigen
ungehinderten Zugang zu schaffen und die
UN soll einen Koordinator für diese
Hilfen benennen und letztlich bleibt es
aber eben an Israel ob es diesen
Forderungen wirklich nachkommt vielen
Dank für diese Einordnung Claudia
BZ wie dringend nötig Hilfe ist für die
Menschen im gaserstreifen zeigt ein
aktueller UN-Bericht mehr als eine halbe
Million Menschen sind demnach dort v
Hungertod
bedroht Wasser Nahrungsmittel und Zelte
kam bisher über Rafa dem einzigen
Grenzübergang zu Ägypten auf
internationalen Druck hin hat Israel vor
einer Woche zusätzlich Kerem schalom
geöffnet von dort berichtet Henriette
diier es ist ein täglicher Kampf um
etwas zu essen eine warme Mahlzeit
ausreichend Wasser besonders die Kinder
leiden unter den katastrophalen
zusten Stunde laufen und können froh
sein wenn wir essen bekommen dann muss
ich wieder zurück um meiner Familie das
Essen zu bringen was soll ich sagen es
ist einfach hart ztausende Menschen sind
in den Süden des gasastreifens
geflüchtet untergebracht in
provisorischen Zeltlagern ihre Lage wird
immer dramatischer die anhaltenden
israelischen Luftangriffe haben tausende
getötet in den völlig überlasteten
Krankenhäusern können die fehlen
verletzten kaum mehr versorgt werden die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation schlägt
Alarm
weltweit gibt es 130 000 Menschen die
akuunger Leiden in Gaza sind es mehr als
eine halbe
Million den geflüchteten im Gazastreifen
fehlt es an allem die Hilfe die bisher
ankommt reicht bei weitem nicht
Entspannung sollen nun Hilfslieferung
bringen die über den wiedereröffneten
israelischen Grenzübergang kimalom komm
seit Sonntag haben etwa 600 LKW
Hilfsgütern hier den Grenzübergang in
kirimchalom passiert sie transportieren
Nahrungsmittel Zelte medizinische
Hilfsgüter Dinge die dringend im
Gazastreifen gebraucht werden
Hilfslieferungen die in Gaza auch schon
erwartet werden die Linderung in großer
notversprechen und doch nur wenig werden
ausrichten
können und die Kämpfe in Gaza
erschüttern auch die palästinensische
Bevölkerung im nahen Westjordanland sie
trauern um die vielen Toten und das
zeigt sich im Moment besonders in
Bethlehem die Stadt südlich von
Jerusalem gelegen ist sonst gerade zur
Weihnachtszeit ein Besuchermagnet doch
obwohl von den rund 33 000 Menschen hier
etwa 3 25% arabische Christinnen und
Christen sind ist in belehem gerade
niemandem zum Feiern zumute Susanna
Santina belehem im Westjordanland gerade
um die Weihnachtszeit tummeln sich hier
normalerweise tausende pilg und
Touristen aus aller Welt doch seit dem
Terror am 7 Oktober ist alles anders nur
einheimischer auf dem Platz wo sonst die
Vorbereitungen in vollem Gange sind auch
der Weihnachtsbaum fehlt so sah es hier
im letzten Jahr
aus wegen des Krieges in Gaza verböten
sich große Feierlichkeiten sagt der
Bürgermeister Betlehem ist in Trauer
deswegen können wir nicht wie sonst
Weihnachten begehen aber es wird eine
Christmette geben
Susan kassabri ist palästinensische
Christin und will vor allem für ihre
Kinder zumindest zu Hause ein bisschen
Weihnachten feiern zu Mute ist dir
danach eigentlich
nicht wie können wir Weihnachten feiern
wenn gerade so viele Kinder in Gaza
getötet
werden ich hoffe dass ich trotzdem
Geschenke bekomme und dass ich den
Weihnachtsmann
sehe auch die festliche Beleuchtung in
den Gassen von belehem bleibt in diesem
Jahr aus und die Betreiber der
souvenirledden müssen um ihre Existenz
bangen wir hatten im Vorfeld so viele
Sachen für Weihnachten bestellt aber nun
gibt es keine Touristen unser Geschäft
ist im Vergleich zu früher bei
Null für die palästinensischen Christen
wird es ein stilles Weihnachten in
diesem Jahr sie solidarisieren sich mit
den hier lebenden Muslimen die ebenfalls
um die vielen Toten in diesem Krieg
trauern in Tschechien wird um die Opfer
des schusswaffenangriffs an der Prager
Karlsuniversität getrauert 14 Menschen
starben auch der Täter morgen soll es in
Tschechien zum Gedenken an die Opfer
einen nationalen Trauertag geben für den
Mittag ist eine Schweigeminute geplant
über den Tag nach der Tat berichtet
Alexandra
wacano sie kommen heute Abend zum Tatort
zünden Kerzen an trösten sich und
trauern wie konnte das nur passieren
fragen Sie sich diese Tragödie hier m im
Herzen ihrer
Hauptstadt es ist schrecklich traurig
heute bin ich hier um eine Kerze
anzuzünden für die Toten weil es mir
unglaublich leid
tut so viele Tote 25 werden verletzt ihr
Zustand inzwischen
stabil vier von ihnen sind auf der
Intensivstation aber alle Patienten die
operiert wurden haben die Eingriffe
überlebt und werden nun weiter
behandelt vorsorglich will die Polizei
die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen verschärfen
und veröffentlicht heute Aufnahmen ihrer
bodycamps nur wenige Minuten nach den
ersten Schüssen sind Sie vor Ort dringen
schnell in die Uni ein und suchen den
Täter die Studierenden haben sich
verbarrikadiert wie sie es in dieser
Situation tun sollten in den
Klassenzimmern wo die Polizei bei der
systematischen Räumung des Gebäudes
gewaltsam in die Zimmer eindringen
musste und so die Barrikaden überwinden
konnte um an sie heranzukommen und sie
nach und nach alle zu
evakuieren das Motiv des Täters
weiterhin unklar vor der Bluttat soll
der 24-Jährige bereits seinen Vater
ermordet haben und Rätselraten auch um
einen Doppelmord es erhärtet sich der
Verdacht dass der Täter auch vor einer
Woche einen Vater und dessen Tochter im
Säuglingsalter in einem Waldstück am
Prager Stadtrand erschossen hat kurz vor
Weihnachten steht Tschechien im Zeichen
der
Trauer
für morgen hat die Regierung
Staatstrauer
[Musik]
ausgerufen Deutschland will auf
erneuerbare Energien umbauen damit soll
mittelfristig auch das Aus für die
Braunkohle kommen bis spätestens
2038 heute wurde eine weitere
Förderstätte offiziell geschlossen nach
fast 50 Jahren macht der
Braunkohletagebau im brandenburgischen
jenschwalde dicht einer der vier letzten
im Lause Revier in jenschwalde wurden
etwa 10 Millionen Tonnen Braunkohle im
Jahr gefördert das waren zuletzt knapp
8% der Gesamtmenge in Deutschland
Cornelia schimensz
berichtet noch ein letzter Blick auf
seinen Tagebau Michael Kadler 33 hat
fast sein ganzes Leben hier in
jenschwalde als stolzer Bergmann
gearbeitet heute nun die letzte Schicht
ein trauriger Tag für ihn und all seine
Kollegen es ist emotional sehr bewegend
weil wir langjährig hier gearbeitet
haben ich arbeite seit 1978 hier und mit
den Kollegen die auch schon langjährig
hier sind ziemlich zusammengewachsen
sind fast 50 Jahre wurde hier Kohle
abgebackert Strom für die DDR Strom für
die Lausitz immer im Plan es ist so dass
wir natürlich bemüht sind unsere
Verantwortung gegenüber der
Volkswirtschaft im vollen Umfang
wahrzunehmen 20 Millionen Kubikmeter
Erdmasse wurden seit tagebaustart bewegt
ganze Dörfer verschwanden für immer
zuletzt Horno die Leak als
tagebaubetreiber schaut nun nach vorn
Windpark und Solaranlagen sollen die
neue Zeit einläuten wir tun als
Unternehmen alles dafür dass dieser
Strukturwandel gelingt wir sind bereit
Milliarden hier in der Lausitz zu
investieren für neue Energieanlagen wir
wollen dafür sorgen dass die Lausitz
eine Energieregion bleibt alle
Kohlekumpel bekommen neue Arbeitsangebot
und doch muss der Ministerpräsident
heute auch
trösten wir sollten in der Politik auch
mehr Respekt vor dem haben was wir
Menschen auch in solchen
Transformationsprozessen zumuten denn
sie sind es die am Ende auch einen hohen
Preis dafür
zahlen und dann singen Michael kantler
und seine Kumpel noch ein letztes Mal
ihr
Steigerlied
h und der sein H
die Förderung für den klimafreundlichen
Heizungstausch soll wie geplant zum 1
Januar in Kraft treten und auch weitere
Details zum heizungsgesetz hat das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium bekannt
gegeben die Grundförderung soll bei 30%
der Investitionskosten liegen noch mal
30% zusätzlich könnten Haushalte mit
einem zu versteuernden Einkommen bis
40.000 € bekommen wer schnell umrüstet
soll einen Geschwindigkeitsbonus von 20%
erhalten
se hat schon Tradition die
Weihnachtsfeier für Obdachlose in Berlin
organisiert von Schlagerstar Frank
Zander und seiner Familie doch in diesem
Jahr fehlt der Star auf seiner eigenen
Feier aus gesundheitlichen Gründen die
Gänsekeulen Rotkraut und klößer haben
den rund 1500 geladenen Gästen trotzdem
geschmeckt seit 1995 bereits wird dieses
Weihnachtsessen für Bedürftige
ausgerichtet und auch heute schlüpften
wieder einige prominente in die Rolle
des Kellners und sorgten für eine
gelungene
Feier so sah es heute zwischenzeitlich
am Hamburger Fischmarkt aus überschwemmt
durch das Sturmtief soltann und auch in
vielen anderen Teilen Deutschlands
heftiger Regen orkanartige Böhen mit
Folgen für die Deutsche Bahn Züge fielen
aus oder verspäteten sich dadurch
rechnet die Bahn auch für das Wochenende
mit einer starken Auslastung mehr zur
Sturmflut von Clemens
Altmann
seit 24 Stunden hat Sturmtief soltan
Deutschland im Griff in Hamburg sind die
HafenCity und der St Pauli Fischmarkt
komplett überspült große Verwüstung hat
der Sturm in Köln hinterlassen besonders
heftig hat es den Stadil Pol getroffen
überall liegen umgestürzte Bäume
Dachziegel der abgedeckten Häuser
schlagen ein wie
Geschosse zwischen Kassel und perbon
stürzt ein Baum auf ein Regionalexpress
der Zug muss evakuiert werden überhaupt
werden die weihnachtsreisepläne vieler
Bahnkunden umgeworfen Sturmschäden an
den Strecken es kommt zu Verspätungen
und Zugausfällen ich bin die ganzen
Morgen schon unterwegs fast 12 Stunden
ich habe nichts gegessen nichts
getrunken und komme h nicht weg morgen
früh um 6 Uhr muss ich an der Arbeit
sein einmal fahre ich mit dem Zug ne
bisschen CO2 sparen und was ist im Hafen
von neuhalinger Siel in Ostfriesland
wird die fre durch den Sturm vom Anleger
losgerissen und an Land gedrückt auf der
ostfriesischen Insel wangeroge werden
rund 95% des touristenstrandes
weggespüt in Bremen fegesack fließt die
Weser in die Altstadt und Fußgängerzone
an der Gaststätte grauer Esel steht das
Wasser halb hoch an den Fenstern
Panzerglas Panzerglas hält alles aus da
können wir jetzt rausgucken und die
Fischchen angucken das tief soltan ist
weitgehend abgezogen in Hamburg hat die
Sturmflut ihren höchstand
überschritten die Schauspielerin Steger
ist tot wie gegenüber dem ZDF bestätigt
wurde starb sie im Alter von 76 Jahren
bekannt wurde sie mit der klammaugshow
Klimbim doch Ingrid Steger war mehr und
konnte mehr eine Würdigung von Cordelia
Strau
Ulknudel und umschwärmtes Sexsymbol
Ingrid Steger in den 70ern das
ausziehfrälein der Nation ihre
Lebensgeschichte ein großes Auf und Ab
sie wächst im vom Zweiten Weltkrieg
zerbombten Berlin auf zu hausebt es kein
Geld und keine Liebe stattdessen
Misshandlungen sie ist schüchtern und
unsicher trotzdem jobt sie als Fotomodel
dann wird sie fürs Fernsehen entdeckt
sexy und unschuldig zugleich die
Mischung kommt an dann ma ich mir sch
und find wunderbar Kim bim ist 1973 ihr
großer Durchbruch die freche Fernsehshow
wirdkult Ingrid Steger spielt Gabi eine
Art
horrorpipiangstrumpf wie wär es heute
mit Revue Fragen Harald Junke und Ingrid
Steger in den 80ern und präsentieren
Sketsche prominente Gäste und
Tanzeinlagen viele Männer liegen ihr zu
Füßen die große Liebe findet sie nicht
zwei Ehen und zahlreiche Beziehungen
scheitern glücklich ist sie eine Zeit
lang mit Regisseur Dieter Wedel der sie
auch für die Reihe der große Bellheim
engagiert die Fernsehauftritte werden
seltener sie spielt Theater geht unter
anderem mit der alten Klimbim Familie
auf Tour private und finanzielle
Tiefschläge bringen sie aus dem Takt
2010 ist sie
pleite sie rappelt sich auf ausgerechnet
eine Rolle in einer Harz 4 Komödie hilft
ihr wieder auf die Beine inzwischen ist
sie dankbar für die schwere Zeit
schreibt sie 2013 in ihrer
Autobiografie in den letzten Jahren war
es ruhiger um Ingrid Steger geworden sie
hatte sich aus der Öffentlichkeit
zurückgezogen und jetzt kommen wir zum
Sport zur Champions League der Frauen
sen die Eintracht braucht ja ein kleines
Wunder ja das Unentschieden zum
Jahresabschluss gegen Benfica Lister
Bonn ist ist wirklich ernüchternd die
Frauen von Eintracht Frankfurt haben das
Weiterkommen nun nicht mehr in der
eigenen Hand dabei hatten sie am Ende
noch die große Chance auf den
Sieg die vierte Minute der Nachspielzeit
faul gegen Frankfurt 11 Meter für
Frankfurt für Laura Freigang aber Paul
hält es bleibt beim Unentschieden gegen
Benfica Lissabon man kann verschießen
aber die Art und Weise frustriert das
war kein guter Schuss die
Frankfurterinnen brauchen ein Sieg um an
Lissabon in der Tabelle auf Platz 2
beizuziehen Reuteler das 1:0 28 minute
doch der Traum vom Viertelfinale bekommt
in der 71 minute den Dämpfer die
eingewechselte Nicole reisler zum ein Z
ein und zum Endstand denn
freigangselfmeter endet bekanntlich in
den Händen der Gegnerin ein bitterer
Abschluss was noch helfen kann nur ein
Sieg gegen die Übermacht Barcelona und
ein pazzer von Benfica
Lissabon Erfolge für die deutschen
Skicrosser beim Weltcup Innichen
Südtirol bei d im schneet treiben
mussten sich Tim ronck aus Unterwössen
und Florian wilmsmann aus Holzkirchen im
Finale nur dem Franzosen chck navorion
geschlagen geben Tim ronek schob sich
mit seinem zweiten Platz auf Rang 8 im
Gesamtweltcup erster Sieg bei der darz
WM da musste die deutsche Nummer 1
Gabriel Clemens zunächst mal kräftig
durchatmen der Halbfinalist des
vergangenen Jahres zeigte einige
Schwächen überzeugte aber auch mit hohen
Finish Gegner manl long aus Hongkong
musste sich in vier Sätzen geschlagen
geben der German giant trifft in Runde 3
auf den an 11 gesetzten
Engländer Dave chisn und für voh im
Alexandra Palace sorgte der erst
16-jährige Luke ller der
Juniorenweltmeister begeisterte die 3000
Darts Fans mit einem souveränen Sieg
gegen seinen Landsmann Andrew gilding
und zog ebenfalls in die dritte Runde
ein läuft bei den Jungs ja das war vom
Sport danke läuft bei dir ja W und zum
Schluss noch ein bildbeleg für alle die
zweifeln er ist wieder unterwegs der
Weihnachtsmann pünktlich gestartet in
rovanami Finland mit seinen rhentieren
begibt er sich vom zauberhaften Lapland
aus auf eine lange Reise rund um den
Globus seine fleißigen Elfen haben für
ihn in den letzten Monaten die perfekte
Route zusammengestellt damit er all die
artigen Kinder auch rechtzeitig zum
Feste beschenken
kann der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt vor
Orkan en Böhen im südlichen Bergland vor
ergiebigen Dauerregen im Staud
dermittelgebirge und vor starkem
Schneefall im Erzgebirge mehr dazu
gleich von Christa Orben das heute
journal läuft an diesem Abend gegen
22:45 Uhr mit Dunja Hayali auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend auch über das
Weihnachtswochenende bleibt es turbulent
sturmtiefstern entfernt sich zwar
langsam aber an der Luftmassengrenze zu
diesem hoch über dem Atlantik bleibt es
bei Sturm und Regen so sind auch heute
Abend und in der Nacht wieder schwere
sturmböhen möglich an der See auf den
Bergen und im Alpenvorland und es regnet
weiterkräftig vor allem im Stau der
Mittelgebirge da gibt es über das
Wochenende immer häufiger Hochwasser im
Erzgebirge und in den Alpen da schneit
es ab heute Nacht auch kräftig im
Nordosten bleibt es trocken hier auch am
kühlsten bis -1° im Südwesten ist es
milder bis 8°. diesen
luftmassenunterschied erkennen wir auch
morgen 3 bis 6° im Nordosten im Westen
und im Süden gibt es 5 bis 11° und in
diesem Bereich ist auch die Sturmgefahr
morgen am größten schwere sturmböhnen
Berglagen und im Alpenvorland in
Gipfellagen orkanböhnen im Nordosten ist
es am freundlichsten von Südwesten her
lässt der Regen etwas nach am meisten
Regen gibt es morgen im Bereich dieser
Grenze dieser Luftmassengrenze von der
Nordsee bis zum er am Erzgebirge anfangs
noch viel Schnee gegen Abend steigt dann
aber schnell die Schneefallgrenze denn
über die Weihnachtsfeiertage bleibt es
mild an Heiligabend haben wir auch noch
Sturm und viel Regen mit dieser
Hochwassergefahr in den Mittelgebirgen
am ersten und am zweiten
Weihnachtsfeiertag gibt's zwar weniger
Wind und weniger Regen und dann schaut
auch ab und an mal die Sonne raus
tschüss